[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle
Eric Boiron je suis chef de cuisine au
terrasses de Clairefontaine aujourd'hui
je vais vous présenter une recette une
canette fermière en deux services
on a la canette qui est comme ça là qui
est bien mise en place on va la boucler
et ensuite on va la ficeler
ensuite on va la mettre en cuisson dans
une poêle ou un récipient qui va au four
nous allons faire une gastrite
[Musique]
on la prend on la met sur un plateau et
on la laisse reposer pendant au moins 20
minutes à température ambiante et bien
au chaud il faut qu'elle soit bien bien
rosé la cuisson parfaite regardez bien
bien rosé d'où l'importance de deux
cuisson à les cuisses se mange bien
cuites et les filets de canettes se
mangent bien rosé on a découpé les
magrets on va pouvoir servir tout de
suite dans des assiettes chaudes et les
cuisses en petits morceaux pour faire la
salade et on y met la sauce bien chaude
on Flandre un tout petit peu la
sarriette voilà donc ça c'est pour le
premier service
[Musique]
et on fait cuire l'ensemble
il faut compter encore deux trois
minutes à partir du moment où on rajoute
des légumes
[Musique]
et on laisse bien cuire jusqu'à
l'évaporation complète du liquide je
vais rajouter quand même un soupçon de
sel il faut faire attention parce que la
sauce soja sale beaucoup on rajoute un
petit peu de poivre du moulin
les cuisses vont bientôt être prêtes
[Musique]
donc là nous avons réalisé une canette
en deux services les cuisses en salade
et les suprêmes bien bien rosé l'astuce
c'est surtout de bien la laisser reposer
[Musique]